the human brain cannot comprehend
the negative it is incapable
yes it's true i'll give you an example
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it i'll prove it okay the
human brain cannot comprehend the
negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something
right and so what happens is we very
often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative
right i can't get apart i
can't get apart i can't get apart
right or um
i can't do this versus i'm going to keep
doing this
i'm going to keep doing this i'm going
to keep doing this
right um and and it's it's such a huge
thing
to convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well
we're supposed to say instead of saying
to children don't eat on the couch we're
supposed to say eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do
pilots know this right it is well known
in the pilot community that when you
tell a pilot don't hit the obstacle
they'll hit the obstacle because what
they're doing is focusing on the
obstacle
skiers know this if if you ever seen
skiers go through trees
do you know how they do that it's very
easy it's actually surprisingly easy
if you go through trees on skis and you
go don't hit a tree don't hit a tree
don't hit a tree guess what you're
watching
you're only looking at trees all you're
doing is seeing trees you don't
understand
how anyone can ski with all these trees
right as opposed to follow the snow
follow the path
follow the path the only thing you see
is the path
skiers know this if you say don't hit a
tree you'll hit a tree
you won't be able to find a path because
all you see is millions of trees if you
say only follow the path
you actually don't see any trees there's
actually very sparse trees there's
plenty of path there's plenty of snow
it's the same thing for you if you focus
on the obstacles all you will see is
obstacles
if you focus on the path through the
trees
all you will see is path through the
trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career
it's literally perspective